first I pretend for your month are you
look so happy bunny oh whoa how are you
party or one party or what I'm not party
for one good to see you I'm Brian is
that the same congratulations the month
you get a bonus so you get a nice stage
you know I'm one of the only employees
I've never made the cut yeah I see you
just put yourself in and what are the
others gonna say about that I'm one of
them I'm Brian stop aids yes come on hey
the other owners out third shot honored
you're the owner and you made yourself
employee a month yeah
are you the man with the g string the g
string receptions tell me to do that
dancing oh no that would probably be
Kevin oh I see I don't know my booty is
all too big to do the last yes okay I
was gonna say can't wait to see that one
I would love to meet the other two the
chef on the lap dance early around other
you only bring them out yeah all right
Kevin and Joe and I we're all equal
shareholders in this business but it was
my plan met you by the hotel Oh Kevin
Kevin Gordon good to see you buddy
Janice's and corn and Joel Joel so you a
lap dancer might have been some laps
with Donna for you I'm not a
professional
maybe okay fine I'm a wild lowing when I
start drinking I get a little stripper
Dakshin going on or the yellow rowdy and
can be the most fun that any young adult
could ever dream of
it's obviously the chef yes restaurant
manager and there's lap dancer bar a bar
manager so who's in charge all three of
us no such thing
so who runs the hotel who's in charge of
the hotel hotel manager job doesn't
really entail much
with free owners normally there's one
that takes the reigns and two other
silent
none of the sound had looked like an
owner well Gordon thinks we don't look
like owners but what what's the owner
look like we bought the hotel nine
months ago right and you guys go back a
long way just kind of met each other 15
years ago and we're confused whether
it's the three musketeers or Three
Stooges
anyway I'm gonna help quick bite sweet
it's been a long journey I'm excited to
taste the food
thank you nicely thank you very much
Gordon's in a lover food Joel works
really hard everything he puts out
everything that comes out the window
it's a great product I can't believe
this hotel is owned by three guys with a
pink dining room pinks the new black
well it's like a girl's bedroom ghastly
ghastly any specials on today we had a
fresh Alaskan halibut with that now that
I'm talking to you I've completely
forgotten oh we had we had the halibut
with a well this is first time I forget
specials don't why don't you check with
the chef all right well you have a
pressure matter right yes and I was a
server to Russian management employ them
um uh Nona yes all the above
employ the month I'm gonna take that
plate back Carly remember the specials
hey hey you forgot the vessels as though
Ryan is kind of forgotten specials I
have seen him do that for the specials
ailable tonight the macadamia and
crusted halibut right let's try this
dagger entrees the lamb shank and then
what's the killer mode or what is door
mean so door a it's just a calamari
steak oh I'll go for that as well okay
thank you I'll keep a little mini thank
you very much welcome once Corden has a
bite from Jules food orange is gonna put
a smile on his face guaranteed
[Music]
you here we go sir just Argo in a red
wine garlic sauce red wine garlic
absolutely rancid a little taste
nothing's halt yeah strange taste you
know that's the first actually the first
time in the history that I've eaten the
escargot
I really and I'm gonna say that I I
don't like it in any way
no escargot tasted like dirty monkeys
disgusting flip-flop if you sauteed a
flip-flop I think that would be a good
good way describing it that was [ __ ]
disgusting I want to run home and get
some mouthwash for sure but I don't know
whatever you need all right yeah cuz I
stink
where's water for it please just 70
little samples of like boy flights
anything regional we've talked about
that but we have not implemented it so
you'd be talking about it for nine
months but you have actually done it yet
no one's even bothered the sort of wine
flights or trying to get it together so
so you got this place almost a year and
you haven't implemented something that
this town thrives on correct
I have you tasted there's a skull I mean
they're stored oh really
I mean you eat here very often where was
last time you guys sat down had dinner
in the restaurant you've never sat down
with all three of us together
strange stranger I'm getting slightly
nervous that nothing actually gets done
here anyway I'm living in hope I have
some more bread for sure I'm coming
right over
[Music]
honey this is our lamb shank that's a
weird-looking lamb shank visually it
looks like the biggest plate of pure
I've never personally had lamb shank
ever being here I do not like lamb you
the Russian manager you don't like lamb
don't eat this Carl yeah I'm the
restaurant manager but I'm not I'm not
the chef Wow
anything I would just call that a dog's
dinner what a mess I do apologize again
yeah I'm totally embarrassed set our
food is this quality I've always thought
it was better hey Joel the lamb shank he
mentioned that the vegetable gravy GU
was a little little too much okay I'm
gonna run this out okay so fine dining
frozen inedible nasty extra man Amiata
I'm amazed what's this one this is the
calamari door a state that's not garlic
in there again is it
there is garlic in there again jeez it's
just how that dish is prepared
everything is just laced with garlic
please be my guest
what was it trying to be a sponge
[Music]